Santa's video games have become more
popular than ever as older generations
of players seek to revisit their old
after-school activities and newer gamers
want to see if by you Billy was really
that difficult most video games aren't
worth a whole lot but there may be a few
buried in your closet that are worth a
few bucks we'll skip the ultra rare
exclusive stuff and focus on games you
may have just picked up at a store back
in the day and have actually played
since values always fluctuate these
prices are based on information from the
date of this video so future viewers
your experience may vary we're also
focusing on loose games because only
nerds keep their video games sealed
sealed and complete games with their
boxes and manuals included often command
even higher prices than the ones
mentioned here start digging through
your collections as we go through this
treasure chest of valuable games Stadium
events US version as the rarest
commercially released NES game Stadium
events only hit a few stores in 1987
before Nintendo pulled the game and
re-released it with its new accessory
the Power Pad the new game became world
class track meet which was coded to work
with the new motion controller pad it's
rumored that only about 200 copies of
the original stadium events sold before
the rest were destroyed so those that
have been found are worth up to $10,000
before you get too excited only the US
version is rare the UK's PAL version
with the white oval Nintendo logo is
pretty common and isn't worth as much
the US version which features a circular
Nintendo logo is the one you're looking
for copies of this crazy rare game are
still known to pop up at thrift shops so
keep your eyes open and your legs limber
The Flintstones surprise at dinosaur
peak by the time surprise at dinosaur
Pete was released in 1994 gamers were
already three years into the
life-changing Super Nintendo
Entertainment System and that mostly
lost interest in 8-bit gaming not only
was dinosaur Pete one of the last NES
games to be released but after 27 years
of reruns interest in the Flintstones
wasn't exactly hot during this time
either
despite ridiculous attempts to
revitalize the
franchise if you happen to be a devotee
of either dying home consoles or caveman
hijinks you may have hit the jackpot
this game sells for around 650 bones
today little sampson
another game released around the end of
the nintendo entertainment systems
lifespan little sampson
saw for sales in 1992 and wasn't noticed
by players until many years later in
addition to being rare it's one of the
few valuable games that's actually a lot
of fun to play with critics comparing it
to adventure Island and Megaman if you
have a copy it's worth around 900
dollars but most authentic retro gamers
will never know the pleasure Outback
Joey before the Wii Fit tried to get
tubby gamers off the couch there was
Sega's heartbeat personal trainer a rare
variation of the Sega Genesis console
which incorporated movement based
controls instead of the usual game pad
only 1000 heartbeat personal trainers
were produced and each came bundled with
Outback Joey a game that monitored your
heartbeat to control a kangaroo decades
ahead of the obesity epidemic the
heartbeat personal trainer missed the
usual gaming audience and remains
relatively obscure Outback Joey still
slipped into a few collections and is
now worth around one thousand nine
hundred and fifty dollars
air raid the vast majority of Atari
games don't have any real value today
but if you have a copy of air raid for
the Atari 2600 you have a piece of
history no one knows how many copies
were released but only 15 have been
found and the company that produced it
meant a vision never made another game
box copies of this UFO invader game have
sold for over 30 thousand dollars but
even loose Kurtz catch around 3000 the
cartridges unique color and shape could
help it stand out from the local flea
markets unending bounty of tube socks
most Atari games aren't worth the
plastic they're made with today but
there is at least one more exception to
the rule Eli's ladder if you really want
to make Bank build a time machine and
use it to buy weird and educational
video games Eli's ladder for the Atari
2600 is another rare example of a
valuable Atari title which originally
saw
it's sales mostly because it taught math
instead of making things explode with
spaceship lasers today a copy is worth
around 1,500 its developers image never
made any other games but the one they
did make left a huge impression on
collectors and math challenged children
magical chase a side scroller starring
an adorable witch magical chase was
released at the very end of the turbo
graphics 16 s production in 1993 while
the game was good enough to be
re-released on other platforms so that
everyone could enjoy it
collectors are still willing to pay up
to four thousand dollars for the
original release which sold poorly
during its initial run in stores we're
not blaming Bette Midler for ruining
witches for everyone but we're blaming
Bette Midler I the Legend of Zelda
Majora's Mask gray not for resale
version if you were friends with someone
who worked at a Toys R Us back in the
early 2000s they may have been sent home
with a copy of Majora's Mask from their
in-store Nintendo 64 demo machines
unfortunately for gamers most of these
demo games were incomplete prototypes
and only designed for a few minutes of
in-store play at a time fortunately for
your wallet
many modern collectors are completists
and Zelda fanatics are typically even
more intense copies of Majora's Mask 2
that are both gray and bear though not
for resale label can be worth up to
$1,300 working retail never looked so
rewarding thanks for watching subscribe
to our YouTube channel to watch more
videos like the one you just saw and
leave us a comment to let us know which
rare games you found in your closet